bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour décrypter ce grand entretien du
chef de l'état hier soir qu'en avez-vous
pensé à nous leurs blanc je commence par
vous
écouter emmanuel mettront par le bien
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est un bel
exercice de communication ils essaient
en réalité de consolider son électorat
et de faire croire aux français que son
mandat a été une réussite
malheureusement je ne peux pas vous dire
que c'est la réalité parce que mon
collègue vous dira sans doute les des
choses différentes mais très sincèrement
en tant que député
sous le quinquennat d'emmanuel macro les
résultats ne sont pas au rendez vous on
voit et moi je fais quotidiennement des
rencontres avec notamment des
commerçants voyez il ya pas plus tard
que deux jours j'étais avec des
commerçants dans le village de mon
territoire du maine et loire qui me
disaient mais at on dit c'est la
catastrophe on va mais prélèvements
urssaf n'arrête pas d'augmenter ah bah
oui mais voilà c'était de quoi qu'il en
coûte du président de la république
c'est sa manière de récompenser les
commerçants qui sont donnés pendant la
crise voilà par exemple on va en parler
plus en détail à un passage qui vous a
plus marqué qu'un autre guillaume
bulletin
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il avait hélas
l'exercice devant la mairie ce qui a été
réussi et qui était digitimes on fera
sans doute sur des débats qui ont
entouré ce cette interview alors j'aime
beaucoup de tracas mineurs blain parce
qu'on a on est une occasion de discuter
de textant en commun pendant tout ce
temps dans cette partie ii du
quinquennat il en effet la raison je
suis à
la maison qu'il a des choses mais c'est
normal c'est aussi celle des bonnes
pratiques c'est pas d'accord je crois
que là-dessus il faut pas faire de
procès quand même au président le en une
période très belle tu dis là même trois
périodes puisque lui même la découpe un
peu comme ça le fait de dire qu'il y ait
d'abord les réformes qui tenait les
engagements de sa campagne électorale
avec une frustration qui est celle de la
réforme des retraites n'a pas été mené à
bout et parce qu'il est le deuxième
période qui était qui s'engagent et qui
est celle de la de la crise épidémique
dans ce contexte évidemment non ce
n'était pas très populaire delà de la
remettre dans ce contexte évidemment
basse et surtout qu'on a eu un beau jeu
la faire et on a heureusement 2010 et
toutes les toutes les forces de la
nation a essayé de franchir cet obstacle
épidémique on n'a pas totalement finie
puisque on voit bien qu'ils aient encore
des vagues qui arrivent mais néanmoins
la france est sans doute un des pays qui
s'en sort le mieux sur le plan
économique parce que les quoi qu'il en
coûte pour reprendre l'expression l'a
asservi et je ne suis pas sûr rencontrer
les mêmes commerçants cannes lambelin
parce que je crois que beaucoup aussi
ont reconnu que l'état avait été la
république avait été là c'est vrai aussi
pour les salariés dans le chômage
partiel avec les aides qui ont été
apportées mais
sur le fond évidemment le chef de l'état
a dit la même chose que vous hier on a
beaucoup entendu parler le chef de
l'état dira j'ai appris d'ailleurs ça
rappelle nicolas sarkozy quand il disait
qu'il avait changé écouter
d'abord elle m'a appris comme à nous
tous ce qu'était cette vulnérabilité que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
et donc cette humilité à laquelle vous
devez être confrontés
ensuite elle m'a
je dirais qu'elle m'a fait sans doute
touché plus
plus directement les inégalités
insupportables qui peuvent exister
lamblin je vous en prie mettez vous à
l'aise cinq ans pour apprendre et
connaître les français et découvrir
qu'il ya des inégalités
comment est ce que vous avez perçu cette
recette phrase du président
les inégalités oui
je veux dire ce qui est stupéfiant avec
le lot l'interview d'hier c'est que le
président de la république fut semble
faire un merde pas sans réellement
expliquer aux français qui va se
représenter alors scrutin donc il essaie
de faire amende honorable mais c'est
quand même un peu je dirais deux
dernières minutes parce que combien de
fois et m'ont collé pourra très
certainement le dire aussi
leur ont demandé de l'eau justement on
connaître les erreurs avaient été
commises par le gouvernement et à aucun
moment le gouvernement le président de
la république dalle corriger le tir et
le jeu gouverna droite à gauche de 2010
elle n'existait plus n'a jamais été et
pendant cinq ans il n'a fait que
gouverner avec sa majorité en
maltraitant l'opposition et donc les
inégalités dans le pays elle existe et
malheureusement il n'a jamais entendu ce
que nous députés de terrain nous lui
avions dit nous on n'a pas changé de
président contrairement à ce qu'il dit
ce qu'il a dit hier je ne connais pas
suffisamment le président pour dire si
la changer ou pas crise a cependant
aujourd'hui
voilà moi ce que je retiens du président
de la république c'était un bel exercice
un bel allocution comme il a toujours su
faire mais malheureusement sur le
terrain les choses ne sont pas de cette
manière là et moi ce que je veux
simplement je regrette c'est qu'il
n'écoute pas les élus de terrain qui lui
ont dit pendant tout son quinquennat que
quelques erreurs ont été commises et
qu'il fallait les corriger ou d'une
terre est ce que c'est normal qu'un
président prenne le temps de connaître
les français quand il est à la plus
haute fonction de l'état
alors je me rends compte que ce n'est
pas tout à fait répondu à notre question
précédente parce que je me suis laissé
entraîner dans le débat avec un anglais
on leur dit qu'ils étaient des moments
du jeu j'avais vraiment apprécié dans ce
don dans le plus apprécié dans ce pays
oui mais ça va faire mieux ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est que il ya un an il y
avait une sorte de décryptage des
phrases qui est qui lui-même parfois
jugée maladroite ou picard et le
contexte
la droite
expliqué et la voyez quand vous dites le
président découvre les inégalités non
c'est parce qu'il a dit ce qu'ils disent
qu'il a découvert s'il y avait parfois
des moments où le sait mais l'égalité
ces directives s'est fracturé la société
était encore au delà de ce qui
l'attendait et je pense que ça
d'ailleurs en tant que député et je
pense que c'est vrai pour tout le monde
les moments où nous sommes confrontés à
des réalités qui sont plus dur que ce
que nous nous imaginions abandonné il ya
en effet de la suie yann en tissage la
chose publique il le dit aussi un autre
mon nom c'est que quand on est dans une
posture public on n'est plus tout à fait
comme les autres de ce point de vue en
effet on nous regarde différemment en
effet on découvre les choses
différemment les gens ouvrent aussi
leurs intimités une façon différente il
ya des réalités qui nous sautent au
visage parfois et justement il faut ça
nourrit aussi pour pouvoir agir
davantage donc je crois que oui il est
tout à fait légitime que dans un point
jeune président l'a dit mais aussi pour
de nouvelles majorités qui pour le coup
c'est un peu table rase delà de ce qui
se passait avant même si évidemment les
oppositions et la corée du nord blain
moi j'ai vu des votes ou parfois nous
étions avec des votes commun avec le
groupe ait l'air parfois plus tôt avec
la gauche laurent même temps existé et
j'ai vu aussi elle en même temps où tous
les extrêmes se regroupaient pour voter
contre nous donc je suis allé au
parlement on avait vu le prêt toutes les
gammes de l'arpège qui est qui étaient
là qui se trouve tout à fait normal
qu'un pouvoir apprennent et heureusement
d'ailleurs hilton se corriger j'écoutais
aussi votre éditorial east juste avant
dire on
va pas commenter et bien sûr de me lier
des pacsés c'est normal et juste des
citations pierre dac ce sont eric quand
on dit que c'est on va la télé pour dire
des choses quand on a rien à dire quand
on est à la télé c'est toujours un petit
peu dangereux mais ça c'est autre chose
quand il disait que ça a duré longtemps
d'écouter le président moi j'écoutais
président a longtemps été par exemple
bas ont-ils été à la rencontre des
maires en effet quels exercices durant
les 4 5 6 1 c'est vrai que ça quand il
était aussi face au au maire et qui est
devenu une réalité il a échangé avec lui
je pense qu'il va non seulement appris
compris elle aussi porter un message à
ce point là alors doit on parler d des
phrases qui avait qui avait choqué les
français au début du mandat d emmanuel
macron yari là il a parlé des gilet
jaune il a surtout mis en avant
d'ailleurs les violences le saccage de
l'arc de triomphe il a salué le travail
des préfets et mais il a eu cette phrase
aussi regarder
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas on
peut souffrir on peut avoir une parole
d'h on peut avoir un avis sur l'épidémie
mais de la crise des îles et jaune à
l'épidémie nous avons en quelque sorte
créé un système on pense que toutes les
paroles se valent c'est pas vrai il ya
des gens qui sont démocratiquement élu
par le peuple pour porter sa voix un
député de la république n'est pas
l'équivalent d'un manifestant quand il
s'agit de parler de la nation parce
qu'il a une légitimité démocratique
alors blain est ce qu'il y avait une
certaine arrogance là dans cette phrase
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas mais
bien sûr que si c'est quand même le
président du conseil de défense qui nous
explique que toutes les paroles ne se
valent pas c'est extraordinaire toute la
gestion de la pandémie s'est fait à huis
clos dans le plus grand secret avec des
gens désigné uniquement par lui en
conseil de défense
effectivement et pour évoquer les chez
les jaunes même si je suis d'accord avec
lui sur le sens que les représentants de
l'état sont et les représentants de la
nation sont là pour représenter les
français le vrai problème c'est qu
emmanuel macron n'a jamais tenu compte
de la voix des gens qui représentent les
français et encore hier pas plus tard
qu'hier je parlais avec un artisan de la
prime des 100 euros la prime des 100
euros qu'on nous a vendu être une prime
pour compenser l'augmentation des taxes
sur le gasoil à falloir plus exactement
les sens alors qu'aujourd'hui on nous
explique que c'est une prime de pouvoir
d'achat sincèrement c'est totalement
hallucinant de voir une gestion à la
petite semaine du gouvernement parce que
nous sommes à quelques semaines d'une
échéance électorale
on voit très clairement que notamment le
mouvement des gilet jaune n'a jamais été
endiguée parce qu'il n'y a jamais été
répondu et je reprendrai naturellement
ce qui a été dit par mme on connaît bien
sûr les grands exercices pour le grand
débat ont été magnifiquement fait les
cahiers de doléances ont été portées en
préfecture et les français ont pu les
rédiger et ont pu mettre sur table ce
qu'ils avaient mais pour autant qu est
ce qui a été corrigé sur le terrain
absolument rien la fameuse prime de 100
euros distribués avec leucan est celle
de la république ne changera strictement
rien si ce n'est potentiellement essayer
de faire semblant et de faire croire aux
électeurs que l'on n'a changé comme il
l'a si bien dit est ce qu'il a réussi à
effacer son image de président des
riches le président c'était aussi le but
de l'exercice
le président de jerry jette un slogan
c'est un slogan qui fait partie de débat
public avec parfois ses excès parfois
ses nuances sa sortie de l'audition il a
démenti qu'il a démenti cette pas cette
image mais ce slogan parce qu'ils
estiment ils ont comme suis d'accord
avec cela que la politique nous devons
mener une politique qui a profité à
l'ensemble des français c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs traduisent les chiffres juste
une petite correction la prime de 100
euros avec une prime qui a toujours été
sur le pouvoir d'achat parce que deux
points de l'aja a été remis et non pas
par l'augmentation des taxes à une lutte
par l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie
ce qui va tout à fait la même chose et
on essaie avec ses 100 euros on me fasse
pour la plupart des français qui évoque
encore une fois ce ça s'adresse aux
classes moyennes et aux classes
populaires qui subissent ou plus le
mérite du coup d'énergie aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas plein dedans on sait ce qui se
passe sur les marchés voulaient
l'énergie qui a été fait donc dont il
vit dans ce n'est pas le président des
riches et une addict voulait gommer
cette image il a simplement refusé cette
appellation qui a été décodé par
l'opposition je pense qu'il ya des
éléments pour y répondre en particulier
des politiques que nous avons menées en
faveur des plus modestes et fils qu'on
ne parlera pas que les que des tribunaux
de l'argent qui va qui est donné en
termes de pouvoir d'achat de même s'il
ya encore une fois des choses
importantes qui ont été faites en la
matière qui en était la politique
éducative qui vise à donner toutes les
chances aux uns et aux autres dès le
départ on est sept
d'aller au bout de ce débat il nous
reste à parler évidemment de
de ce discours de candidat c'est ce que
dénonce l'opposition même si emmanuel
macron ne sait pas clairement encore
prononcé au cours de ce débat il a donné
quelques pistes qu'il se projetait sur
sur dix ans donc ça en dit long il a
parlé de il a peut-être il s'est peut
être adressée aussi à valérie pécresse
ça en parlant des de la suppression des
fonctionnaires regarder
où sont les fonctionnaires l'éducation
nationale vous m'avez dit à juste titre
le plus important ce nos enfants pour
faire quoi réduire le nombre de
professeurs pour réussir à à innover
faut réussir à ce qu'ils aient plus de
temps de professeurs avec les élèves
soient en classe soit en accompagnement
les en accompagnant les devoirs donc oui
on doit améliorer le système mais ce
qu'on peut dire je peux supprimer la
moitié des postes d'enseignants voyons
où sont les fonctionnaires les policiers
ah la belle affaire c'est vrai qu'on les
a on les a supprimées en l'air la
sécurité ben non on est la recrue en
lézard remis en place parce qu'il en
fallait sur le terrain et que nos
compatriotes à juste titre veulent de la
sécurité où sont les fonctionnaires les
magistrats les mêmes qui nous disent
anodine il faut au moins 9 mélo démis le
magistrat
quelle division qu'elle bataillon
lesquels ou faut du sérieux il faut du
sérieux et une mauvaise approche divine
président et allusions évidemment à la
mesure de valérie pécresse qui elle vit
en supprime une centaine à leur blanc
sait c'est bien un discours de candidat
qu'on a entendu hier ou pas
écouté j'espère que nous pouvons faire
confiance aux c'est ça pour
véritablement tranché effectivement que
ce discours était un discours de
candidat qui ne veut pas le dire parce
que ça fait bien d'attendre un petit peu
et de faire croire qu'on travaille
encore même si tous non c est notamment
lorsque l'on siège au parlement que les
derniers mois sont consacrés au
renouvellement des mandats revoilà vous
savez très bien mon cher collègue que ce
qui est aujourd'hui voter n'est que des
réformes et des petits textes pour faire
plaisir aux uns et aux autres et que
malheureusement il ne se passera
clairement rien de manière légistatives
jusqu'aux présidentielles
ce qui est certain c'est que lorsqu'il
aborde tous ces sujets il fait
évidemment une réponse à valérie
pécresse mais tout ça n'a pas ça ne fait
pas illusion ce que propose valérie
pécresse un discours pragmatique et de
bon sens que nous n'avons cessé de
répéter au président durant ces cinq ans
oui bien sûr qu'il faut baisser le
nombre de fonctionnaires
emmanuel macron avait aussi l'intention
dé baisser tout la dune en même temps
c'est à dire que vous faites quoi alain
et alors ce que vous allez faire ce que
vous ce que vous ne serez pas avec
l'autre enfin brisé et je reviendrai pas
sur cette ambiguïté présidentielle mais
simplement sur la question des
fonctionnaires nous nous pensons
foncièrement à droite que nous pouvons
faire mieux avec moins et plus efficace
donc la question n'est pas le nombre de
multiplier dedans d'engendrer à chaque
fois des embauches et des embauches tel
un tonneau des danaïdes
mais au contraire de faire avec ce qui
est l'existant et d'utiliser au mieux
l'existant nous avons aujourd'hui
notamment dans l'éducation nationale un
certain nombre d'enseignants qui ne sont
pas devant des élèves donc il faut que
nous permettions de donner l'ensemble
des clés aux moyens au système notamment
l'éducation nationale de mettre ces
enseignants devant les élèves de manière
à augmenter
le nombre d'enseignants devant donc nos
classes de baisser des effectifs est de
permettre notamment en zone rurale de ne
pas fermer des classes alors vous
parliez d'élèves emmanuel macron yara a
aussi lu une lettre qu'il a qu'il a
reçus de d'élèves
on ya vu évidemment une allusion à à ce
qu'a dit eric zemmour notamment sur le
remplacement sur la polémique sur les
prénoms français sur le grand
remplacement il a répondu à la question
il a dit que c'était une absurdité que
ça n'existait pas regardez cette
séquence
ses enfants m'ont créé les absurdités
consistant à dire immigration zéro ya
jamais eu d immigration zéro c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai alors c'est pas le
bon groupe on extrait on va écouter la
lettre lue par le président de la
république
noël sébastien milla cheikh mansour
faustine héloïse kenza daniela guillaume
livi emma ryan karam
ses enfants m'ont créé in here de
mauvais prénoms sont ses enfants m'ont
écrit une lettre voilà pour axe est une
lettre des colliers voilà pour cet
extrait à guillaume gille tait c'était
une c'était une allusion à eric zemmour
honteux part reproché au président
d'être absente du débat qui va commenter
des balles
non c'est pas une question est candidat
il ya une chose qui est claire vient pas
je ne lirai gentiment à ma collègue hier
soir elle l'avait lavé de ses collègues
qui étaient en séance avec moi comme
d'autres jusqu'à minuit parce que nous
avons un texte de bois qui est examinée
qui s'appelle qui porte sur la
décentralisation et jeudi à paris que
dans les débats qui avaient lieu on y
considère que ces mesurettes nous avons
la présence française l'union européenne
qui fait en sorte d où leur expliquerai
levée des interventions qu'ils ont
développé je pense que ça veut dire
qu'ils jugeaient qu'il a des muscles
importants de funk été votée et qu'il
voulait d'ailleurs posé dessus et c'est
bien normal c'est le débat parlementaire
et donc il ya la présence française et
l'union européenne et comme les essences
forte et les évidemment la situation et
limitons s'il est tout à fait légitime
que le président s'exprime et par
ailleurs dans un angle interview on l'a
sollicité pour aussi commenté les
récentes de choses et oui bien sûr le
fait de dire il ya des mauvais président
non qui seraient attribuées à des
enfants et qu'un message y ait une part
odieux et qui ensuite faire en sorte que
on sépare les bons des méchants
des enfants aux niveaux délirants de
naissance et leur naissance ont dit que
simple prénom permet de caractériser
quelqu'un dans son devenir dans ce qui
sera et s'il sera un bon français ou pas
c'est une absurdité je pense que c'était
important aussi et c'est le rôle du
président de la république dans ce
personnage symbolique aussi de dire les
choses le dire ce qu'est le respect des
valeurs de la république en effet le tri
par les prénoms ça n'est pas respectueux
de l'adapter à l'heure de la turquie
merci beaucoup il nous reste
malheureusement peu de temps pour pour
ce débat merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france